what's up reject nation it is jon
here in case you haven't been following
the channel for the past
week or more uh greg is out of town
until friday but uh we
endure and we actually have a couple of
trailers that drop today i'm excited to
check out the first of which
is the new bad batch trailer
star wars keeping it going on disney
plus
dave filoni and company the only people
who can please the star wars fans
i'm excited to check this out we checked
out the uh original teas back
when they were first announcing all
their new slate of star wars content
last year and if i'm not mistaken
this drops on may the 4th star wars day
2021 at least we got something to look
forward to
this summer oh yeah and if you could
just do me a quick favor hit that like
button and remember to subscribe
that would mean a lot to me and i know
it would mean a lot to greg as well
let's jump into this
a test is an order five enhanced clones
more capable
yet they exhibit a concerning level of
disobedience
nice nice
nothing but trouble
we get the job done
you're climb force 99 you know who we
are
let's go
this is for the noobs this trailer
it's a well-rounded team
i want clone force 99 found and wiped
out
the galaxy's a dangerous place to be oh
fennick sand get out of here go mcna
what do you say kid you want to come
with us how can i help
hey
the clone wars have ended
you can either adapt and survive oh
or die with the past
we do what we do
oh not not bad i feel like the future of
star wars if you're if you're continuing
on part of the key is you gotta have a
kid
i feel like they they they really
learned
some lessons from the phantom menace and
nowadays they have just like the most
adorable children characters
accompanying like the
galaxy's most infamous badasses
i don't know why that's the first thing
that they grabbed me here but yeah you
know it'll be nice to have
this child character here to be our sort
of audience cipher at least for those of
us who are like me
who haven't seen all of the clone wars
just yet i have started it i'm working
my way up there's a lot of content to be
covered throughout the days weeks months
year but i have been enjoying it so far
obviously the
clone force 99 gets introduced towards
the end of that
um but yeah i mean as far as a group
goes to continue
these star wars animated series i mean
they seem like the perfect
bunch because they are so badass they
also have you know the personality angle
and this trailer like i said was a nice
way to sort of set the stage for people
especially like me
who know characters like grand moff
tarkin and obviously you know fennec
shannon because of the recent uh you
know appearances on the mandalorian and
stuff like that but this was a really
cool sort of
place setter and tone setter for the
rest of the show and what's to grow
out of the clone wars and i love you
know the yeah the star wars does
have this tome like quality where there
are so many pockets of the universe and
there are so many
expansions whether they be via book or
video game
or tv series like this and uh yeah i
mean the animation style looks like it's
grown
that much more from the last time i've
at least from
from what i've been watching of the
early clone wars and whatnot and that
was something that we brought up uh in
the previous video too
is like as a viewer coming into this
before i was sort of curious as to
whether the animation style
would hook me just because it was one of
the barriers for me in wanting to start
clone wars in the first place was i was
in that sort of ignorant mindset of like
it's a really kitty animation
but i really like the way that they've
grown it here um
because you know obviously it maintains
that sort of cartoon-like
design quality but at the same time you
know it's a lot more detailed i really
like their lens
choices and stuff like that just like
the focus you get
and even just the light quality like the
fog in some of these environments and
the way the light goes through it
especially in some of these action
sequences like this looks like
it'll be a visually dazzling and also
very swashbuckling
and action-packed series and it does
continue to bring me to one of my
favorite aspects of any star wars story
which is just
the explorations of the world and the
different
uh settings locations and cultures that
are on display
and i mean you know this is a trailer as
compared to the last one too you know i
think they know that a lot of fans are
going to be
you know jumping in with the full
knowledge but also a lot of people are
probably going to be coming in just due
to the increased interest in star wars
on disney plus
so this makes for a good quick
reintroduction to hunter echo tech cross
hair and
wrecker um but also you know you've got
grand moff tarkin you have
fenik shan for fans of the mandalorian
and then you also have i think saw
guerrera pops up in here too so you have
some
extra characters who have either popped
up in the clone wars popped up in the
original trilogy popped up in the
mandalorian things like that so again as
they expand the world and sort of
marry the gaps together it's interesting
to see how they bring all these
different elements apart especially as
again the live-action movies have kind
of struggled to do that
but yeah the action in this looks really
cool again the worlds the star wars
aesthetics are on
full display and uh yeah i mean this
seems like a really
fun group to set the next installment of
your star wars animated series around
and i mean that that whole thing at the
top with moff tarkin and him being like
these guys have incredible militaristic
capability but they just do not care to
follow the rules
you know like of course they would be
the biggest a big threat
to uh the empire or anybody who gets in
their way but you know that's sort of
that classic thing of
you know that's what makes them so great
at what they do
is the fact that they don't care that
much for protocol and they're
going to improv and take things in
whatever direction they see fit but yeah
what did you guys think of this trailer
hit me up enlighten me as to all the
things
and references that i didn't catch um
and yeah i will be excited to check this
out when it drops on may the 4th
star wars day thank you guys for
watching if you joined me remember to
like
subscribe check us out on patreon if
you'd like to support the channel more
directly
uh really appreciate you guys both here
and over there and
yeah i'll catch you in a few minutes uh
for the spiral trailer much love
[Music]
cheers